okay hi everyone can you hear me
um i uh so good morning good morning to
people in
california in any case and good evening
to michal
and i'd like to welcome mikhail today
who's our theoretically speaking
uh speaker and she's going to talk on
market design
and through the lens of apostolation let
me tell you a few words about michal
and then i will tell you sort of how
we're going to handle questions and
answers
[Music]
[Music]
um
research and uh she studies and analyzes
algorithms
and options markets networks
under the sort of lens of uh economics
if i understand correctly with emphasis
of course on efficiency robustness
which you'll tell us about today and um
what else i want to say i want to say
that michal has gotten lots of best
paper awards from
several conferences in particular from
conferences on computation and economics
and she
is a member of the young academy of
science in israel
and she's the recipient of arc grants of
fellowships
of various kinds and um
she uh is an editor in many places
and she's also listed in the on the list
of the 50 most effective women in israel
and
in the market under a certain age and in
general she's a wonderful speaker
i uh welcome her and we should all
welcome her
first of all i'm gonna do with the clubs
because we're on a zoo in addition to
that i want to say how you can pose
questions so there are two ways to do
this that is take questions at the end
or throughout and i think that
mikhail is going to welcome both modes
of questioning and formally speaking i
think the way you do this
as you type your questions in the q a at
the bottom of the control panel
and then can look at them and i guess
one more mo
one more thing is about this series uh
so as you know the simon's institute was
put in place by a generous
donation by uh of jim simons 2012
and we have had this series running for
quite a while
which is uh theoretically speaking it's
open to the
wide public and teaches us interesting
trends in computation and related fields
so the truth is the series that i like
the most and i learned from the most
so i'm really curious to hear what khal
is to say welcome mikhail and
take it from here thank you very much
let me just try to share
my screen
can you see my slides
excellent okay so thank you shafi for
the kind introduction thank you for
inviting me
it's always such a pleasure to be in
berkeley
even if only virtually um i'm speaking
to you from israel so it's night
time here um and um as i said being in
berkeley
has this effect on me that it's always
like a time machine takes me 20 years
back
to the happy times of my phd studies
so whenever i'm here i feel like a
student again which is
a great feeling so thanks for the
opportunity
i'm going to talk about market design
through the lens of approximation
and i must tell you i really
hate it that i can't see your faces um
i i tried to ask for a regular zoom
session but i understood that
uh due to security concerns it was not
possible
so please do ask question i hope
that i'll be able wait let me just make
sure
i can see oh for some reason i cannot
see the screen with the q
a um
[Music]
okay only one q a here that and which
reports noise which i think was when i
was speaking there was some paper
wrestling okay so
okay hopefully i'll be able to do that
um
sorry michael you don't see the q a uh
okay let me see now
okay now i see noise good okay
excellent so i can see that great yeah
it was just at the top of the screen
and it's always nice also to give
to give talks to as i understand this um
series to to wide audience
and i understand that it may even
include high school students
which is also heartwarming so welcome
everyone and thank you
very much for coming to the talk and i
hope you'll take something from this
talk
um okay so
uh let me start with this figure so in
the
end of the last century the internet has
emerged
into our lives um with many
new and exciting applications and
markets pretty much every transaction
we care about socially or economically
moved to the internet
the internet became a huge computational
platform
for many new markets
and applications like adword auctions
and uh voting and spectrum auctions and
routing and social networks and cloud
computing and everything everything is
moved to the internet
and as a result of this
entity something very interesting
happened
um these disciplines computer science
and economics and when i say economics i
mean economics and game theory
which have evolved totally independently
until that point along
this joint path started to merge
and exchange ideas between them
and this exchange of ideas are flowing
both directions
on the one hand computer science
applications that we really care about
require economic and game theoretic
reasoning for example
in computer science the tradition
traditionally
we just assume that we write protocols
we write algorithms
and our users are obedient they'll just
do whatever we tell them
so if for example we do congestion
control in the internet and we run tcp
we just assume that everybody will run
the beautiful protocol we have written
and suddenly we are faced with this
completely decentralized entities entity
the internet which is owned and used by
many users with competing interests and
everybody is doing whatever is best for
hair
and we had to adopt the strategic
behavior or model so our users are not
obedient and sometimes in computer
science we also assume that maybe the
users
are adversary adversarial but suddenly
we are faced with
entities that are not obedient and not
adversarial
they'll just do whatever is best for
them whatever is in their best interest
and this is in in this sense computer
science had to adopt
the behavioral model and the language of
economics and game theory talking about
strategic behavior incentives and so on
and so forth
and in the other direction suddenly
economists as these uh these
huge markets that are run on a
computational platform on the internet
and um many considerations that you know
they did not they they were not used to
to care about
they suddenly had to to worry about like
computational complexity communication
complexity
algorithms approximation and and this
language started to infiltrate
their area
and um okay so here is the theme
of this talk so i think whenever we
think about
uh computer science and economics i
think the image we have
so if you if you you know you walk into
someone and ask what's the image you
have when you think about computer
science
i think they'll tell you this binary
world zero one
beats everything is binary if everything
is dichotomous like
the the opening figure that the nice
opening figure we had here it was full
of zero ones this is
what computer science is in people's
minds and
uh in contrast economics is about this
continuous world where you have these uh
curves etc and the thing that i'm going
to
to talk about in this uh talk today
is i want to argue that it's exactly the
opposite
i want to argue that traditionally
economics emphasized
exact and optimal solutions so usually
when you read economics paper you read
about
optimal solutions exact solutions
and in contrast computer scientists
always look at
the world through the lens of
approximation so maybe we should say
computer scientists are compromisers
and i want you to remember this image in
mind as i as i move on
and we'll get back to it and we'll we'll
try to understand the roots of this
theme but let me digress a bit and
before i
i start and go to this computer science
versus economics
let me give you a quick really brief
introduction to
the theory of games and economic
behavior what is the game
so a game is a mathematical model of
some real life scenario
almost every real life scenario you can
think about can be modeled as a game in
every
game we have a set of players and each
player
has a set of strategies from which
she chooses so for example
maybe we are the players
today and each one of us needs to
decide whether to arrive to attend
the talk or not okay
um and each player gets some payoff
depending
on the chosen strategy so maybe i
decided whether i attend the talk
or not and shafi decided whether she
comes and other participants each one of
you decide whether to comment
for every strategy profile meaning
everyone decides what their strategy is
each one of us gets a payoff so maybe
you know maybe if i don't show up today
your payoff will be
pretty low because i'm the speaker but
maybe if someone else doesn't show up
it's not that bad
uh and we have a table of payoffs for
every strategy profile
and the the crucial thing is that every
player asks to maximize
their individual payoff okay everyone
and this is the assumption that i'm
going to
carry over throughout this stock this is
not always true we all know that we have
some
you know fairness considerations and
some of us
are altruistic but let's just play along
with this assumption that everybody asks
to maximize their
individual payoff so here is a classical
game
that many i i i assume some of you have
heard of these it's called prisoner's
dilemma
in this game we have two players we have
the row player
uh so the strategy is choosing between
cooperating and defecting
and we have the column player that is
also choosing between cooperating and
defecting and inside every cell for
every strategy profile we see the payoff
of the role player
and the column player so the game behind
this game
is we have two guys with um who are
charged for a crime
that entails five years in prison say
and but we don't have enough evidence to
put them in to convict them
so we put them into separate rooms and
we ask them whether they cooperate or
defect
and if they both cooperate
then we don't have enough evidence and
they both
serve one year in jail okay so we see
that the payoff of the role player is
negative one this means that
he serves one year in jail and the
payoff of the other one is also negative
one
if they both defect on each other
then meaning they talk they say yeah we
did it then they boast their three
three years in jail and the interesting
thing
is that if one of them cooperate let's
say the column player cooperates
but the rope layer defect so we're in
this cell
then the the role player goes free he
becomes a
state witness and the cooperator serves
all
five years in jail okay so this is the
game so now we've completely described
the game and the question is what should
you do
if you are one of these prisoners
and uh it's called a dilemma but really
um
solving this game is pretty easy and i
want to claim that in this game
defect is a dominant strategy what's a
dominant strategy a dominant strategy is
a strategy
that is best off for you regardless of
what other players are doing
okay so this game is completely
symmetric let me take the rope player
and let me describe to you his reasoning
so if the column player cooperates
then i say okay if i cooperate i serve
one year in jail if i defect i go free
of course i want to go free so i defect
if my friend defects then if i cooperate
i serve five years in jail if i defect i
serve three years in jail again i wanted
effect so no matter what the column
player is doing i want to defect
so i have a dominant strategy in this
game
let's look at another game let's call it
election game um
and let's assume the population is
distributed
uniformly along this say zero one
interval
and we have our players now are the two
parties
right right and left parties
and they have to decide where they place
themselves
okay when they sell themselves to the
you know to the
citizens and the assumption is
that every citizen let's say someone who
is located right here
will just vote to the party that is
closest to them
okay so a guy here would vote right a
guy here
would vote left because left is closer
to them
and in this game it's not very difficult
to see that there is no dominant
strategy
the best strategy for each party really
heavily depends on the choice of the
other player
the objective of course is to attract as
many citizens to
of the population to vote for you and
really depending on what the other party
is doing you want to move right or
left so how do we reason about
such a situation and luckily
um nash joe nash came to our rescue
and he uh introduced this very beautiful
notion of an equilibrium
which is um just a stable outcome
what does it mean it's an outcome it's a
strategy profile
such that no individual player can gain
a higher payoff by deviating
unilaterally to another strategy okay so
we are located in some strategy profile
each one of us decide
on the strategy and no one can improve
her situation by deviating to another
place to another strategy and okay this
is a very nice definition but you know
definitions are cheap
let's do what we can do with this
definition so the claim to fame of nash
is that uh in in 1951
he proved that eve every finite game has
a nash equilibrium okay and
by the way we may need to use
randomization not every game has
a nash equilibrium in pure strategy
maybe we need randomization
but every finite game has a nash
equilibrium
this is really a beautiful theorem
showing
uh the generality of this notion
so let's uh analyze these games so
prisoner's dilemma is easy
um we have dominant strategies so of
course if every player is doing their
dominant strategy this is this must be a
nash equilibrium
right because no matter what the other
player is doing um
that's that's what's what's best for us
and let's look at this game
this profile is not an equilibrium
profile
why because the left party here is
attracting
really not so many people not so many
voters
and if the left partner moves a little
bit to the right
it will attract more and more voters
from
the middle and it's not very difficult
to see
that the only equilibrium in this game
is where the two parties are essentially
identical
both of them are located exactly in the
middle and each one of them is
attracting exactly half
of the population okay so this is an
equilibrium of the game
okay so now that we've understood what
an equilibrium here
is let's move on to talk about another
family of games called network routing
games and they want to take you about
100 years back to 1920
and show you this very nice example so
here is the game
we have a a network of roads
and let's suppose we have a huge one
unit of traffic
supposedly we have uh infinitely many
drivers
and all of them want to go from
point s to point d from source to
destination
as fast as possible okay and
they have two options they can go either
through this
short but narrow road in on the top
or they can go through this long but
wide road
in the bottom
okay a crucial uh component in this
network routing game is the cost
function of the edges
so every edge has a cost function
describing
the delay a driver will have on the road
for x fraction of the traffic
for example this road has a cost
function c
x equals x this means that if x fraction
of the traffic
goes here each driver incurs a delay of
x
hours for example if half of the traffic
goes on the top road
each driver will drive for half an hour
if three quarters of the trophy goes on
the top road
each one will drive 45 minutes etc
the bottom road is very different okay
so we see that the top road is very
prone to congestion it really depends on
the congestion
the uh how long it will take to to drive
on this road
the bottom road has a is completely
different
the delay on this road always take an
hour
so this road is not sensitive to
congestion no matter how much traffic
goes here each driver
drives for exactly one hour okay because
this is
this is a long road it takes always an
hour but it's very wide so it's not
sensitive to congestion so
and this is the game the game is all the
players all the drivers
wake up in the morning in cts
and they have to decide whether to take
the top road to d
or the bottom road to d
socially what we want to do is of course
minimize average delay
how do we do that so it's not very
difficult to see
that the optimal thing socially would be
to send if we can
control traffic we would send half the
traffic on the top road
each one of them will drive for half an
hour
and we'll send half the traffic on the
bottom road
each one of them will drive an hour and
this is exactly the right
balance to get us to the optimal average
delay which is three-quarters
okay i hope you can see this
now the question is this an equilibrium
can someone so this is a strategy
profile half of the traffic goes up
after the traffic goes down
can someone improve their delay by
deviating
and the answer is of course they can
improve
those people so let's take one driver
who currently
i put him on the i i told him drive on
the
you know bottom road he drives for an
hour
and if he goes up and think about this
every driver is this
infinitesimal uh unit if he goes up he
drives
about half an hour why not and every
driver
it does exactly this reasoning and what
would happen
is that the only equilibrium is one
where all the traffic
goes up all the traffic takes this very
narrow road which is very sensitive to
congestion
and everybody is driving one hour
so we went up from the optimal solution
everyone is driving for 45 minutes to
if to the equilibrium solution where
everybody is driving for one
hour okay this is bad
now the question is how computer science
is relevant here i told you about
droughting games i told you about
equilibrium
and about a hundred years ago pigou
observed that
in such a situation the optimal solution
is not an equilibrium and an equilibrium
the only equilibrium
is not optimal so in equilibrium we are
suboptimal
okay this is a nice observation and now
comes the
the very special angle of computer
scientists
and what i want to argue here that
computer scientists
are really compromisers and we are so
used to look at the world
through the lens of approximation that's
what we've done
over and over again and i want to
present to you now
three generations of of compromise
of compromises and we always do the
following we have some object
objective function f and we measure
our performance by taking the
performance
in a restricted world we are restricted
in some way
maybe computationally maybe
informationally maybe in some other way
we are restricted and we do whatever we
can do in this restricted world
and we compare ourselves the performance
against a benchmark
in this perfect unattainable
unrestricted world
okay and this is what we are used to do
that's what we do this is how we look at
and analyze the world
for example in the 70s cook harp and
levine developed the beautiful theory of
np
completeness the restrictions was
computational restrictions we wanted
algorithms that run fast
and always are always optimal and then
kukharp and levin
identified these np-hard problems that
well what can we do probably we cannot
solve them always
fast and always optimal and what we did
was develop
approximation algorithms
how do we measure the performance of
these approximation algorithms
we take the value that can be achieved
by a fast algorithm
polytime if you will and compare it to
the optimal value of
f if we had all the time in the world
without the computational restrictions
of course
this denominator this optimal value is
only describing some utopia
we are not we don't even think we can
get there but this is
a benchmark against which we measure the
performance of our approximation
algorithms
and then in the 80s we started to think
about informational restrictions
and we started to develop the theory of
online algorithms and competitive
analysis and again
we used exactly the same formalism a
completely totally different concept but
exactly the same formalism
we said what happens if the input to our
problem arrives piece by piece and we
have to make decisions immediately now
without
knowing what's coming in the future so
the most relevant problem back then was
paging
where we had slow memory
um but very big and we had a
very fast memory very small and we had a
sequence of page requests and we
we had whenever a page uh request
arrived that was not in the cache
we had to decide immediately which other
page to evict
and we had to make this decision without
knowing the future
so these are called online algorithms
and by online here i don't mean internet
i mean online
in real time okay how did we measure the
performance of online algorithms
we used exactly the same thing the value
of f
of f obtained by an online algorithm
compared
with the benchmark and this time the
benchmark was the best
offline algorithm an algorithm that
knows the future
and we called it a competitive ratio
and then the third generation of
compromises
in the 90s we started to have
we already had the internet and we had
this problem
where we can't control our users we want
to
write algorithms we are faced with some
scenarios
and our users just follow their heart
they do whatever is best for them
they follow their best interest and they
act strategically
and just like we've seen in this routing
example
and they do they play in equilibrium and
this is what a cortopias and
papadimitrio called the price of anarchy
so we measure such scenario we just
follow what we are used to do
approximation and we want to measure the
performance of some scenario
by taking the ratio between what
what we obtain in equilibrium and we
compare
it to the socially optimal value okay
and because of this uh history sometimes
uh papadimitrio for example calls it the
third compromise the price of anarchy is
the third compromise
so let's look more carefully into this
price of anarchy thing
because this concept will we'll just use
it throughout this stone
so again what's the price of anarchy is
that is the value we have some objective
function f
and the price of anarchy is the value of
f that is obtained in equilibrium
and we compare it against our benchmark
which is the socially optimal value of f
for example in this routing example we
have drivers
and they'll do whatever is best for them
this is what we get in equilibrium
and we compare it to this you know
centrally controlled
world where we could if we could control
the drivers and tell them where to drive
so the price of anarchy really measures
the performance loss due to strategic
behavior and i want you to note that the
price of anarchy is defined with respect
to some objective function
usually we take just social welfare we
want to
optimize the sum of people's values
or minimize the sum of people's costs if
we're talking about
losses it's defined with respect to some
solution concept and we usually assume
just
nash equilibrium so we we assume that
people are playing
a nash equilibrium and also this is
something
uh i didn't tell you until now in some
games we may have multiple equilibria we
may have more than one equilibrium
so we have to decide which equilibrium
we choose and usually we just
follow the computer science the approach
of doing
worst case analysis so the price of
anarchy unless i say otherwise
it's the social welfare this is obtained
in the worst nash equilibrium
compared to the socially optimal value
of f
okay i think this is a good place to
pause and ask if you have questions
i'm looking at the q and a i don't see
open
questions if you have any questions
please do type them i really appreciate
the interaction
okay
so in what follows i'm going to study
the price of anarchy in
three families of games one is network
routing we'll have some
good news there the second is network
formation games we'll have some bad news
and then the last one will be the fcc
spectrum auctions
and here we'll have next news
i think that uh there is a question now
two questions
yes okay great and also i i wanted to
ask a sir
a third where you could give us some
better more explanation about socially
optimal examples of socially optimal
values there okay okay great so the
first question
is um anonymous and he's asking is the
price of anarchy always going to be
greater than one
great question great observation yes the
price of anarchy is what
is going to be greater or equal to one
if it equals to one it means that in
every equilibrium of the game we are
going to be
optimal every equilibrium will be
socially optimal
this is the this is the dream this is
the best case scenario if the price of
anarchy is one
we have nothing to worry about a
completely unregulated free market
will do just just as well as a
completely regulated market
we don't need to control our users and
of course it's always greater or equal
than one because socially optimal is
optimal by definition
if it's huge it's really bad news so
when i say bad news i mean that the
price of anarchy is huge maybe
maybe it's even not any constant maybe
it's it's um you know maybe
it depends on the number of users and
because we are talking about
internet applications with hundreds and
thousands and millions of users
if the price of anarchy is going to be a
function of the number of users
we are doomed it's really bad it's it
means that
um we really need to regulate the market
otherwise we are going to be
really really in a bad situation okay
um the second question can you further
describe online algorithms wow i wish i
i had the time to further describe so
online algorithms are just
great um this is an amazing topic
and uh so let me just say a few words
about it
so online algorithms you have you you
you get
you have some sequence of you you get
your in
input piecemeal you get it piece by
piece
and in every time you have to make a
decision
immediately and irrevocably here is a
very classic example
secretary let's say for example
secretary problem
you are interviewing secretaries and you
have
and you see them one by one and in every
time let's say you you interview
and secretaries and every time you see
the performance
of the one you just interviewed and you
can compare
the the performance of this secretary to
previous ones
you have no information about the future
and now you interviewed someone and you
have to make a decision now
whether you hire the secretary or not
okay how do you do it and we compare
ourselves to the
to the best thing if we could see
all the sequence the sequence up front
okay so there are some nuances so maybe
so
maybe for example the arrival order is
random or maybe
we know an underlying distribution and
we have all types of
things of assumptions that can make our
life easier
but in general this online algorithm the
question is to compare the performance
of an algorithm that needs to make
immediate and irrevocable decisions to
an algorithm that knows all the future
and sometimes we do we we can do pretty
well
so this is about online algorithms now
to shafi's question about what's
socially optimal so i'm not sure what
exactly you mean by this question but
for example in in this routing example
that we had before suppose so what's
socially optimal here
socially optimal here means that we have
the minimal
average delay right or average delay or
sum of delays doesn't matter okay i
guess
i wanted more examples but yeah oh more
examples okay we'll see more we'll see
we'll see several more examples uh yeah
but the the point is if we can control
our users we can just do what's optimal
but the problem is we cannot control
them
um okay what's the price of anarchy in
the city problem
great question we'll get there very soon
doesn't it make sense to ask for
equilibrium only amongst
feasible eg polytime computational
limits
excellent excellent question so this
question hints
on a very important question that i'm
not going to talk about which is
computational complexity
of of finding an equilibrium
and sometimes one criticism there is for
the price of anarchy
is that why do we even assume that
people will get to an equilibrium
right especially if it's compu if it's a
computationally hard problem
it's really uh it casts doubts
on the predictive power of equilibrium
because
you know if it's an npr problem for
example why should we get there
excellent question
hopefully i'll have some time in the end
to talk more about it
um could we as audience please see
all questions i don't know that's that's
probably question for an admin
and uh the last question if the agents
can communicate to some extent and
collaborate will the price of anarchy
disappear
amazing question and i'll answer this
question in
the second game i'll talk about
excellent questions thank you so much
and um
hopefully i'll be able to satisfy all of
you so let's
keep going so we have the price of
anarchy
and um great we've defined
it and now one of the question was
what's the price of anarchy in this
city game in this network routing game
the answer is the price of anarchy here
is the cost in equilibrium
compared with the cost the optimal cost
and the answer is is four over three
okay four thirds is this good news
is this bad news so let's let's see what
it what
it what it means and this is for this
very specific example
what it means is that in this figure
network that i just showed you
the overhead due to selfie selfish
behavior is at
most 33 so i take it to be
really good news okay it means that
if we had all the control in the world
we could control drivers
the situation would not be that much
better on the or the contra positive now
that we are in a complete anarchy
anarchy meaning
equilibrium everybody is following their
best interest
yeah we are we are suffering an overhead
of
33 this is not that bad
and this is a universal constant this is
just
four thirds it's not too bad but you
know
this was just one tiny example of two
cities and two roads
in real life we have way bigger networks
and the networks are so complex we have
you know complex
network of roads and bridges and cities
and et cetera et cetera also the cost
functions that i showed you were
were very simple and different roads
depending on their structure
have very different uh cost functions
and also i assume that all the drivers
want to wait from
s to d in the morning different drivers
want to go from different sources to
different
uh destinations and it becomes a real
mess okay and the question is
what's the price of anarchy in this very
general scenario
and the amazing answer of rough garden
and tardis from 2002
is this theorem in every
network routing game as long as the cost
functions on the edges are linear
or a fine just like the ones we've seen
the price of anarchy is at most five
thirds
it doesn't get worse than an overhead
of 33 percent no matter how big the
network is no matter how many drivers
are there no matter
how the cost functions look like as long
as they are linear
okay so this to me is an amazing
question
amazing answer i mean
okay um let me do a small digression
here which i feel is important
so price of anarchy results are
quantitative in nature
we really ask for you know four thirds
five halves etc etc
and you know some of us this cartoon
describes some of us i admit that
sometimes i can get really excited by
getting an approximation ratio down from
two point blah blah blah four to two
point blah blah blah
three nine um but
and it's fine for you know mathematical
curiosity it can be very important
but we have to remember that price of
anarchy results
like approximation results they are it's
true that they are quantitative in
nature
but they provide mainly qualitative
insights
about problems we care about so for
example in this price of anarchy result
the four thirds result really tells us
that in
network routing problems in network
routing scenarios
the overhead due to selfish behavior
is not that bad
let me show you one more example which
is
really incredible it's called process
paradox and
it's from 1968. again we have one unit
of traffic now the network is a bit
different um we have uh
four roads two of them are of type x
and two of them are of type one this is
the cost function on the edges
again the socially optimal
way to drive is to just route half of
the traffic up half of the traffic down
right and this gets us a delay of three
halves after trophy goes for 1.5 hours
the other half
goes for another 1.5 hours and the
average delay is
1.5 and now suppose the government
look at this situation and says wait
you know every driver driving every
morning
for one hour and a half from say
san francisco to berkeley this is no
this
no way we have to make it better and the
way to make it better
is to build this very fast road
that goes from this point here to this
point
there and this road is so fast that you
can think about is there is a
teleportation right people just move in
no time from this point to this point
with the hope that this will reduce
congestion
and get people faster from s to d
okay let's analyze what happens next
again the socially optimal thing
is to do exactly the same thing route
half the traffic
up and half the traffic down and again
have a average delay of 1.5
1.5 however
unlike this case where this is an
equilibrium
right you can see that in this case
everything is symmetric there is no
reason for a driver
in the bottom row here to go up or vice
versa
now due to this very fast teleportation
road we're in a problem because people
have incentive to take the zigzag road
so someone who is driving for one hour
and a half here
can say oh well i can just take the
zigzag road
drive half an hour here zero here and
half an hour here
boom i do an hour instead of 1.5
but everybody will do this reasoning and
what would happen is that instead of the
best average delay
of 1.5 the only equilibrium would be
one where everybody is taking is taking
the zigzag road
and then what happens everybody is
driving
oh i have to wave in order to get the
light back on
everybody is driving for two hours now
wow so we built a new ward a new road
and the situation became much worse
by the way surprisingly enough the price
of anarchy is again
four thirds right right it's
two over three over two so again four
thirds this is a coincidence
um and we know it cannot be worse than
further so this is the worst it can go
it can get okay and what's the takeaway
from this example
the takeaway is that building new roads
could potentially
increase travel time for everyone and
this is the new thing that we see in
this example
it's not just for some people it's
really worse for everyone
and the contra positive that closing
existing roads
could potentially decrease travel time
for everyone
and throughout history we've seen real
life examples
for this phenomenon so for example in
stuttgart in germany
it happened that they built a new road
in order to
alleviate the congestion and this new
road just
slowed down traffic really badly until
they had no choice but to close it
and then the situation became better
okay so what seems
locally optimal sometimes is really bad
globally
now let's go back to this uh beautiful
theorem
of four over three um
how come we did sorry
how come we didn't see this result
before so this
pico example with price of anarchy of
four
thirds just celebrated its 100th
birthday
and it took about 80 years to come up
with this result
and the answer is it's not
that the proof was so difficult it's
definitely non-trivial proof
a beautiful proof very nice proof all
these price of anarchy proofs are really
nice
and non-trivial but it doesn't take 80
years to prove them
the reason that we took 80 years to
prove them is that we really needed the
point of view of computer scientists the
ultimate compromisers
in order to even ask the question and
once the question was asked
we could answer it or in this case tim
rothgarden and eva tardis
okay um let me take a few more questions
um okay when you say the price of
anarchy can be huge
it takes the worst case equilibrium is
there a pareto ranked equilibrium
then coordination can result in better
outcome has this been explored this has
been explored and i'll get to this
exactly this point in the next uh in the
next application i'll talk about
um it was supposed to be anarchy
auto spell maybe i had a typo story is
there an optimal value for the price of
anarchy
what should it oops what should it be
less than to be able to control the
situation
ah good so what's an optimal value for
the price
of anarchy so in our analysis as
computer scientists
we are looking for tight
results so when we say that the price of
anarchy
is for example four thirds in order to
say
that this is optimal or this is tight we
have to make the case
that indeed on the one hand it's always
bounded by four thirds and on the other
hand
we have an example where we get four
thirds so we cannot get
better than that and then we say that
the price of anarchy
is tight um
shouldn't we compare the overhead with
the ratio of a random algorithm
okay great question and they take this
question to be
so i only described to you pure nash
equilibria
until now but as i told you before nash
equilibria also may be
random and if we are going to
mix nash equilibrium this is a much
bigger
class of equilibria this is really a
very very beautiful question the answer
is
that by now we've developed the
theory of price of anarchy and we have
machinery
that gives us some extension theorems
so in many situations we can prove
it's it's kind of a magic we can prove
price of anarchy results for this small
class of pure nash
uh equilibria and the ratio
the the the ratio we obtain for the
price of anarchy
extends also to
larger classes of equilibria such as
mixed nash equilibrium or maybe those of
you are familiar with the terms
correlated equilibria and course
correlated equilibria
and in some cases even just outcomes
that are obtained by no
learning algorithms et cetera et cetera
so we have extension theorems that allow
us
to to prove price of anarchy results in
some situations
for a small class of equilibria and they
extend magically
beyond too many other types of
equilibria
because of course potentially price of
anarchy could become much
larger if we go from a small class to a
larger class
okay where csid is useful in the proof
again excellent question
um okay let me just finish reading or
once you ask the question
do you use essentially standard math
ideas
so in this case it was cs
ideas were not used in the proof so we
had to ask the question
and then we just used math in this case
it was potential function
that played a major role in these proofs
thank you again for all the questions
and let me continue
with the second application um with the
second application we'll get to some of
the questions you were interested in
great second example
network formation games so now the
figure is very similar to before but the
situation is completely different so
just stay tuned to hear the story
the story here is that we have again
now a population of n players
and uh they need to build a network
and they they are all interested in this
case to connect
s the vertex s here to the vertex d
here so maybe for example they want to
lay down
internet fiber between neighborhoods
okay and they have two strategies two
options
one is to build this very expensive edge
and the other is to build this cheap
edge
okay and you see now that you see the
cost on the edges
so the cost of this edge is n it's as
big as the number of players
and the cost of this wire of this edge
is one
great so we have n players they wish to
build a network connecting s and d
and each ad each edge has a fixed cost
for building it
for building it uh this fixed cost is n
this fixed cost is one
and note that in this case unlike the
previous example
the cost of the edge is independent of
the number of players using it
no matter how many players are using it
it has a fixed cost and this is of the
cost of
laying down this fiber no matter how
many players are going to use it
and here is the important thing the cost
is split
equally among the players using it okay
so if for example all n players let's
say we have 10 players and the cost of
this edge is 10 and all 10 players use
this edge each one of them will pay
one because they split the cost and
equally between all players and if they
all use
this edge they'll each
pay one over n and if they split
they'll just pay their equal share of
the edge
let's analyze this game and what's the
goal the goal
is to minimize the total cost of the
network we need a network that will
connect s to d and we want to choose the
minimal
uh cost in order to connect these two
points
okay and again this is a very very small
network
just two edges imagine you have huge
network with many edges
and many players each set of players
want to connect
different parts of the network and every
edge has a fixed cost etc etc
but let's analyze this very simple
scenario
what's the optimal thing of course
what's optimal
is that everyone uses the bottom edge
and then the total cost of the network
is
one all and agents all and players
choose the bottom edge this is great
this is very cheap way
to connect s2d however
we have a really bad equilibrium
if all the players are building the top
edge
each one pays one and no one has
incentive to deviate
alone unilaterally to the bottom edge
okay and this means according to the
definition of nash equilibrium
that this is unfortunately a really
bad equilibrium and the price of anarchy
here
is in is as
big as the number of agents
and if you're curious about this example
i'm not going to show the proof but the
proof is very simple
so convince yourself that it cannot be
larger than
m okay so n is tight the price of
anarchy in these games
is in it's always bounded by n even in
these huge
networks that i described to you
okay but something is really bothering
us
and this all it is and and the thing
that bothers us
is related also to one of the questions
that one of you
asked before why think about
worst case equilibrium we have
a really nice equilibrium here if
everyone is using
the bottom edge here this is also an
equilibrium of course everybody is
paying only one over n
and they don't want to deviate and pay
any loan
so why why are we thinking about the
worst case equilibrium another question
that was also asked in one of your
questions
is maybe people can coordinate
this nash equilibrium thing is really
annoying
it means it's stable only in the sense
that one player has no incentive to
deviate a loan
but if all the hundreds and hundreds of
people are using
this top edge and paying this huge
cost maybe a few of them can coordinate
a deviation and go here
maybe all of them can coordinate a
deviation and go here
so this equilibrium makes us feel
pretty bad it feels like a very brittle
equilibrium
and indeed we have
two results two approaches of eluding
this
bad price of anarchy the first approach
as one of you suggested is to consider
the best nash equilibrium
instead of the worst nash equilibrium
and to just
ask do we have any nash equilibrium that
is performing well
and the result that we have here is that
the cost
of the best nash equilibrium is at most
factor
order log n of the optimal cost okay
so now we have an exponential
improvement
over the really bad price of anarchy
that could be
just in number of uh players we went
down to login and again this is tight
there is an example of a network where
we have only one a unique nash
equilibrium
and it's it cost factor log n more than
the optimal one
okay so great this is the first approach
the second approach is to stick towards
worst equilibrium
you know we are computer scientists we
are so used to worst-case analysis we
really want
things to be good in the worst case
but what we will do now is consider a
different solution concept
so as i told you nash equilibrium is a
situation where
no individual player can deviate and
improve her cost
let's consider a subclass a strict
subclass of nash equilibrium called
strong equilibrium
this is due to oman another nobel
laureate
who came up with this notion of strong
equilibrium
and the strong equilibrium is a much
more stable outcome
it's an outcome from which no coalition
of players
can deviate in a coordinated way
and improve the cost of each member
okay and what we get here
again we get the cost of the worst
strong equilibrium is at most factor o
log n of the optimal cost so in both
cases this
new definition of price of anarchy the
first takes the best nash equilibrium
the other takes the worst strong
equilibrium
they both arrive at this same
price of anarchy same loss due to
strategic behavior
and um i think it's interesting so the
the it may be a coincidence that we get
exactly the same results that the
the proofs are completely different they
both of them
use again in all of these proofs both in
the network routing game and in this
network formation games this is a
these are both called uh they are both
part of a larger class of games called
a congestion game and usually the way to
deal with such games is
through minimizing a potential function
so we have
so these are also potential games we
have a potential function
and in order to find a nash equilibrium
we want to find the local minima
of this potential function so both of
these proofs
are related to this notion of potential
functions but otherwise the proofs are
different and it's interesting because
these
two notions these two approaches
are related to some type of coordination
in the left in approach one
the coordination is really coming from a
third party
who just suggests
the players to play in some equilibrium
maybe the best equilibrium
and because it's an equilibrium they
won't deviate
so this is some one type of coordination
coordination
through a third party on the other hand
approach 2
is again some type of coordination that
helps us
but this time the coordination is coming
from the
users themselves they coordinate
themselves by coordinating their
deviations
and both of these approaches turn out to
give us a price of anarchy
of login
okay let's take questions again
how often our cost functions linear how
often are the cost functions linear in
real world networks so i assume you
uh talk about these network routing
games
very good questions usually they are not
linear
usually they are more quadratic than
linear
and we also have results uh for
for um just polynomial of a bounded
degree
cost functions uh and if the degree is
small
which is what's more common in roads
maybe
you know cost function is kind of
quadratic then we also have good price
of anarchy results that depend on the
degree so if the degree is small we have
nice results as well are those
equilibria cost
login for games in general or a class of
games
so these login results are for these
specific
network formation games just for this
family of games
um of course not only for this example
that i showed you of two
edges it's for this very general network
formation games
where you have a general network and any
fixed cost on the edges and any
player wants to connect some node to
another node
a so logan holds there but not beyond
this
network formation game
[Music]
is there a different solution concept
for which the price of anarchy for
network formation game is constant
um unfortunately i'm not aware of one
if you find one i'll be happy to know
um okay and then
a comment about approximation here is
the famous quote
of bernard russell although this may
seem a paradox all exact science is
dominated by the idea of approximation
great so this idea of looking at the
world through the lens of approximation
goes back to bernard russell thank you
vijay
okay let's continue um
[Music]
last example auctions shafi how much
time do i have left
we have an hour and a half allocated for
this but if you wanted to take
a go203 uh 15 say and then ask
leave room for questions so i don't know
much more okay
good so i'll just continue and i'll ask
and i'll take questions um in between
and also in the end
okay great okay so the third example
is auction design okay
auctions are really now everywhere we
have
keyword auctions we have auctions on
ebay
advertisement are now sold by auctions
and they are really the biggest
part of the business model of most
internet companies so most of the
revenue of
internet companies is now obtained using
auctions and of course fcc auctions for
wireless bandwidth so wireless bandwidth
is sold to telecom companies
using auctions from i think the mid-90s
or so
government procurement auctions
everything is done using auctions
and you probably know and if you don't
know
uh you should know that you have these
keyword auctions so every time you type
a word in google
and search for it you get some
results which are the the generic
results but you also
get sponsored results and these results
that you get
are sold through auctions to the
advertisers
okay so if you write a hotel san
francisco
because you want to find a hotel in san
francisco
you so online in real time there will be
an auction
and and and this auction will be among
all those advertisers that want to sell
you
their hotel or maybe car or rental etc
etc
so we really have now auctions
everywhere
so as a warm-up um i just cannot
not tell you about this wonderful
auction called second price auction so
let me tell you let me do a warm up
about a single item object so really
what's more interesting to me
is these are these huge auctions of
millions of items and millions of users
and and
they are everywhere but let me just zoom
in for a minute and tell you about just
an
auction for a single auction okay so
here is the model
we have one good for sale maybe this
picture and we have n beaters and those
end bidders have values v1 to vn
so in this case for example we have this
bidder
her value for the picture is 20
this means that she is willing to pay 20
dollars to obtain this picture
the goal is to allocate the picture to
the bidder with the highest value
let's assume i don't care about revenue
at all
all i want is to sell it to the bidder
with the highest value
okay in this case i want to sell to this
lady
the problem is that the bitter values
are private i have no idea
what the values of the bidders are okay
for example
if i want to maybe give one of you
my cell phone here i want to give it to
the person with the highest value but i
don't know
your values and i do an auction
and in this auction this is the image i
want you to have in your head
this auction so we have these values the
values are
private they're in the heads of the
agents i don't know them as the
auctioneer
what i do get is the bids
of the agents every agent submit a bid
let's say they submit bids in sealed
envelope
okay so each one of you for example
sends me now
a bid for my cell phone using private
chat
and i open these bits and every auction
is composed of two
rules one is an allocation rule
and the other is a payment rule i have
to decide and both of these rules are
functions of the bits
only bits i don't know values i just
know bits
okay and this is a very very beautiful
auction called second price auction or
vicry auction
this is a very simple auction that does
the following
i collect all your bids i open all the
envelopes
i give the item to the highest bidder
the one who submitted the highest bid
but that bidder
doesn't pay his bid he pays the second
highest bid okay so if i got beats let's
say
a hundred and eighty and sixty
i give it to the bidder who bid a
hundred
but he only pays eighty dollars
why is this auction so great
we have this wonderful magic by another
nobel laureate vicry
saying the second price auction is
dominant strategy truthful
this is amazing so you know just take
uh 10 seconds to appreciate this result
what does it mean
it means that if i'm running second
price auction
each one of you doesn't have no one of
you
has any reason
to misreport your value so you have your
own private value
but the the best the absolutely
one best thing for you to do is to tell
me your private value
truthfully you have no reason
to somehow misreport your value so
the best strategy and this is not just
an equilibrium
this is a dominant strategy no matter
what others
are doing no matter what the values of
other no matter what are the bids of
others
the best thing for you to do is always
to beat your true value
this is amazing okay and this is
what's called a second price auction and
just after the talk think to yourself
what about
first price auction for example what if
the payment was
just the bid i give it to the highest
bidder and
she needs to pay her bid would it be
truthful
it won't be truthful and no other
auction would be truthful this
is the truthful auction and this is when
i'm selling
one item but now we are talking about
huge auction let's
for example think about those wireless
spectrum auctions
we are selling many many licenses to
telecom companies
and these licenses since the mid 80s are
sold in what's called simultaneous
ascending auctions
so uh it's not that important
the details are not that important
what's important is that every license
is
sold in a separate auction but
the bidders the telecom companies have
very complex combinatorial valuations
over licenses
so sometimes two licenses can be
substitute to each other
if for example they are in the same area
some licenses can be complement to each
other
maybe you know i want a license in
san francisco area and then in berkeley
area
so those valuations can be very complex
and we are selling many items and in
order to handle such situation we have a
canonical model called a combinatorial
auction
where we have n bidders m
heterogeneous items so in our case for
example the bidders are the telecom
companies
the items are the just the licenses
wireless channels and every bid are high
every telecom company has a private
valuation function
over the item over the items and this
valuation function as i said can be
really complex it assigns just a real
value
to every bundle of item we're just
making one assumption that the valuation
function is monotone if you get
more items if you get more licenses your
value doesn't go down
very very minimal assumption
the social goal is to maximize social
welfare
the social welfare here is the sum of
bidders values
okay so just think about this situation
we have many licenses we have many
telecom companies
each one of them has a very complex
valuation function
over all these licenses and we want to
partition to
partition those licenses among the
bidders
in such a way that the sum of their
values will be maximum
and we're using an auction and remember
auction is composed of an allocation
rule and payment rule
based on bids so now think about bids
as you know maybe in this complex world
a
bid would be just the whole valuation
function
very very complicated um object
and the individual goal of reader i is
to maximize
her own utility what's her utility
her utility is the value she has
for the bundle she gets minus the
payment
minus what she has to pay for
this bundle okay good
let's make a simplifying assumption and
let's suppose
that what we are doing is simultaneous
second price auctions
so i told you about this beautiful
second price auction when i'm selling
one item alone
a second price auction is dominant
strategy truthful
it's best thing for me to just say my
value truthfully
but now i have a very complex valuation
function
and the auction is such that every item
every license is sold separately so i
have
to just give one bid for each license
and then for each license we are running
a second price auction with all the bids
that
the auctioneer got and the question is
is this a truthful auction
so we know second price auction is
truthful if we do simultaneous item
simultaneous second price auctions is
this truthful as well
and the question is of course not
because as a bidder i don't even have
the
expressive power to tell the auctioneer
my va my my value
my value is this complex object over
bundles of items
and i am i and i can only
give bids on separate items so this is
not truthful
and i don't even have the chance to
reveal my valuation
so the question is how do we analyze
this game what's an equilibrium of the
game
what's the price of anarchy what's the
efficiency loss etc
and just to give you the feeling of how
difficult
analyzing this uh this game is suppose
we are we have 20 licenses for sale
and suppose you are a telecom company
and you are interested only in a single
license
how should you bid
so one option would be to go
all in to identify one license and go
all in for this license and don't bid on
anything else
well this might work for you but this is
also very risky because if you don't
win this license you have nothing
another option
is to be low on many licenses
and hope that you'll get one of them but
remember this is tricky because in the
end you only get value from one license
and you pay for everything that you win
how do you balance
all these trade-offs and now
suppose you want two licenses
how should the answer change and the
answer is
i don't know the answer analyzing how to
play in these games
is really really difficult let me skip
for the sake of time
this example and skip directly
to the result
i think if you want to you have 10 10
more minutes before we kind of
record the end so if you want to give
some time for
okay good so i'll just say this result
and then i'll end
so the result is as long as items don't
have strong complementarities
and what i mean by don't have strong
complementarities
is just that my evaluation function has
this
what's called submediative structure
that my value
for s plus t is smaller than the sum of
my value for s
and my value for t this is a pretty
general class of valuations
simultaneous second price auctions have
small price of anarchy
okay and this is for any number of
agents
any number of items and even under
incomplete information
so this is a pretty strong result
and um
[Music]
uh okay let me skip this two
the takeaway from this is the simple
auctions work well in the absence of
strong compliments
and now we are going back to our
question how come
all the beautiful literature in
economics didn't reveal
this beautiful pattern so this aligns
with their with with their thought they
thought
that these simple auctions work well
if items are substitutes to each other
and and and complementarities bring us a
lot of mess
but they didn't have any such uh any
such result
any such theorem and again the answer
that the reason they didn't have it is
not because
the the proof was so difficult again
it's non-trivial
but it shouldn't take so many years the
answer is the reason is that they never
asked this question it's really the
approximation length the approximation
paradigm
that we use as computer scientists that
make us ask these questions
so okay now i'm in the concluding
uh slide so first of all
uh what we've what uh i showed you today
is that the approximation length of
computer science
appears very useful in many economic
applications
and now i want to take to do a little
zoom out
uh the fruitful interaction between
computer science and economics go
way beyond this team so today i just
showed you one theme how do we use
approximation the approximation paradigm
in order to reason about economic and
markets
uh situation but the interaction really
goes way beyond this example
and if we take if we're doing even
another level of
zooming out i think this is
really the golden age of theoretical
computer science
i think the world is matured into
interdisciplinary research
and uh for the last few decades
tcs has developed its theory it's
beautiful theory
internally and now it's the time for tcs
to come out of the backstage and
really influence the world and we are
seeing it
in many with many many examples
computational biology
is computer science and biology quantum
computing
is computer science and physics
algorithmic game theory economics and
computation computer computer
science and economics and i believe that
we'll see
many more examples in the near future so
just
take tcs and you where wherever you want
to take it
thank you very much thank you very much
michael and those are fantastic words
also for the simons institute for tcs
um which i agree with uh you have three
questions it looks like in the q
a if you want to address them okay
um are results available only for such
toy models or are there ways to make
statements about
real systems um
right so um
usually in order to have uh tractable
models we are doing many assumptions
and we have these examples some of them
are really toy examples
like the you know the the small example
with two bidders two items or a
very small network but some of them go
beyond
toy examples they are still you know
assuming some
real world things away
but they are reasonable like
simultaneous second item auctions i
think
they are good models for like
good approximation let me let me use
this word again
for these uh simultaneous ascending
auctions that
are used in practice um
okay and then another
i okay so bernard
fonstangel is saying i ran my own
auction for
selling an inherited house for bidders
and open auction would have been awkward
and also a second price
auction the bidders would have thought i
wanted to deceive them
first price was straightforward you say
what you would pay
and that's it and the information stays
private
would you sell your house by a second
price auction
simplicity and trust are important too
okay yeah uh great i take it more as a
comment
than then is a question so sure
yeah great comment um
[Music]
okay any thoughts on what the price of
anarchy with respect to how we are doing
vaccine
distribution today is the allocation
socially optimal wow
this is a beautiful question um i have
many thoughts
on i have many thoughts on this and i
have some
ideas some of them are a bit provocative
so maybe i shouldn't
uh tell them i'm not familiar with the
research precisely about price of
anarchy
of vaccine distributions today maybe
what i am familiar with is a research
that is integrating game theoretic ideas
into the sir and similar models
so the sir model is you know with this
model of
how the how the pandemic
goes um i'm running out of words
um diffusers say among the population
and the assumption there is that people
interact randomly which is
with each other and they get sick and
they recover et cetera et cetera and we
have these differential equations that
tell us how the dynamics will be
and they these models completely ignore
strategic and game theoretic issues so
there are some new papers that are
trying to incorporate game theoretic
ideas
into those sir models for example if the
pandemic is really in a really bad
situation now
it's reasonable to assume that people
will be
much more careful than otherwise and
taking
these assumptions into account and into
the differential equation
changes the type of dynamics and i think
this is a very very worthwhile
idea because i think really people are
taking uh into account
we should take into account the
strategic issues
people respond people do best respond to
whatever the situation is
um another uh comment by steve tadellis
hi steve
there is a lovely new paper by aquapor
and lee in econometrica on the benefits
of
first price auctions in the spirit of
the house selling question
um oh okay i take it to be related to
the question or comment
by bernard um sure um
those are two amazing authors and i
encourage you to read this paper and
i'll read this paper alone
let me also tell you that of course i
only uh introduced to you today's social
welfare is an objective
of course we have many more objectives
in particular of course we also care
about revenue revenue is a
very very important uh objective
function
and things are different when we talk
about revenue
than when we talk about uh social
welfare
but those of you who are not familiar
with a beautiful
theorem called our revenue equivalence
theorem
so if we if we for example we compare
first price auction
and second price auction so in first
cross auction the winner
uh pays his bid and in second price
auction the winner pays only the second
highest bid
and okay people will behave differently
and the question is
what can we say about the revenue in
equilibrium
and we have this beautiful theorem
revenue equivalence theorem
saying that in equilibrium the revenue
will be equal
because in equilibrium the revenue only
depends on the allocation
not about the payment so um yeah this is
not really answering the question
but i i just felt that i talked so much
too much about social welfare so
revenue deserved maybe one word
okay wonderful and you even finished on
time
um i think
we just want to give you a big applause
which means nothing in virtual days but
i will
clap for you and thank you so much
michael also for staying so late and
giving such a wonderful talk in such an
exposition of the field
uh thank you thank you very much
and uh thank you very much for for
coming and
it's such a shame i couldn't see your
faces
but uh we'll do another and another zoom
session for this i guess
thank you bye thank you bye bye